Transcriber: Ömer Faruk Zeren
Gözden geçirme: Emel Çırakoğlu
Merhaba, hepiniz hoş geldiniz.
Burada olmaktan çok mutluyum.
Birazcık da heyecanlıyım.
Ben İrem Arslan.
29 yaşındayım.
İstanbul'da yaşıyorum.
Bir bankada Reklam ve Halkla İlişkiler
bölümünde 5 yıldır çalışıyorum.
Lise döneminde iki sene
tiyatro eğitimi alarak
İmam Bayıldı isimli oyunda rol alarak
oyun sergiledim, harikaydı.
Ödül aldım.
Grubunda yer alıyorum.
Grubumla birlikte
farkındalık yaratmak için
farklı yerlerde görüşmelere katılıyorum.
Türkiye Büyük Millet Meclisine bile
gösteri yapmıştık.
Gördüğünüz gibi çok
sevdiğim hobilerim var:
dans, tiyatro, konserler veya partiler.
...
Aynı zamanda ben bir özsavunucuyum.
Gene kimlere el konuldu?
Onlar kim?
Özsavunuculuk nedir?
Haklarım hakkında konuşmak.
Kendi haklarıma ve
sorumluluklarıma lider olmak
Kendi hayatım hakkında karar vermek.
Neler yaptık?
Sağlık hakları, sosyal haklar,
bağımsız seyahat etme hakkı,
seçim ve seçilme hakkı,
eğitim hakkı, okuma hakkı gibi
hakkımızı savunmak için Down Türkiye
seyahati özsavunuculuk grubunu oluşturduk.
Türkiye Büyük Millet Meclisinde
milletvekilleriyle buluşup
orada bir komisyon
kurduk.
Taleplerimizi ilettik.
Örneğin hastanede sıra beklememek, toplu
taşıma araçlarında öncelik verilmesi
seçim ve seçilme hakkının olması.
Karabük'e gittik.
Orada Down sendromu
hakkında bilgiler verdim.
Tıp öğrencilerine sağlık hakkında
tavsiyelerde bulundum.
Doktora gittiğimde anneme değil
bana cevap olmasını istedim.
Özsavunuculuk grubu olarak
yoksulluk ve sosyal sorumluluk konusunda
çalışmalar yaptık.
Yoksulluk ve kentten dışlanmanın
tanımını yaptık.
Yoksulluk ve sosyal dışlanma ile ilgili
ne yener bunu konuştuk
Bu proje kapsamında Ömer ile
birlikte huzurevine gittik.
Orada yaşlı insanlarla sohbet ettik,
mutlu olduk.
Özsavunuculuk grubu ile birlikte
Budapeşte’ye gittik.
Orada sunum yaptım.
İş hayatından bahsettim
ve huzurevine ziyaretimi anlattım.
Macaristandan gelen insanlarla birlikte
sosyal sorumluluk
konularında etkinlikler yaptık.
Orada evi olmayan, kimsesiz insanlar için
Çeşitli çalışmalar yaptık.
Hepimiz yemek pişirdik
ve kalan yemekleri yoksullara dağıttık.
Böylece yardım etmiş olduk.
Bir etkinlikte yoksul insanlara
alışveriş listesi çıkardık,
çok az para ile yoksul insanların...
bu para ile marketten alışveriş yaptık.
Bekleyecek gıdaları almak çok zordu.
Bu süreçten sonra pandemi başladı,
özsavunuculuk grubumuzu
internet üzerinden devam ettirdik.
Toplantılar yaptık.
Online yapmak en başta zordu
ancak alıştık.
interneti kullanmayı
hep birlikte öğrendik.
Dernek Yönetim Kurulu Başkanı ve Milli
Eğitim Bakanlığı ile beraber
online bir toplantı yaptık.
Bu toplantıda başarılarımızı
dile getirdik.
Bir özsavunucu olarak
Sizlere söylemek istediğim bir şey var:
Ben olmadan asla benim adıma konuşmasın
kimse karar vermesin!
Hadi, hep beraber söyleyelim. Ben
olmadan benim hakkımda asla.
Olmadı.
Hep beraber
Beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.